ده عم اشرف شغال موظف في شركه نقل
الاتوبيسات وبيقبض 5000 جنيه الثلاجه
بتاعته قديمه وكل شويه تبوظ وبيصلحها لحد
ما زهق منها قربي يشتري ثلاجه جديده راح
سال على ثلاجه مناسبه لاحتياجاته تلاقيها
ب 6000 جنيه فقرر يحوش 500 جنيه كل شهر
للثلاجه وبالتالي المفروض بعد التحويش
يشتريها بعد سنه عدت سنه هو بحط ال 500
فوق ال 500 كل شهر تحت المرتبه لحد ما حوش
ال 6,000 جنيه وراح المحل يشتري ولكنه
اتصدم لما عارف ان نفس الثلاجه بقت ب
7,200 جنيه يعني سعرها زاد في خلال سنه
حوالي 20% وبالتالي في الفلوس قيمتها قلت
بنسبه 20% بسبب التضخم ده مثال بسيط جدا
بيحصل باشكال مختلفه مع كل واحد فينا في
اي بلد عايشين فيها مع اختلاف نسب التضخم
من بلد للثانيه التضخم هو وحش لا يشبع
بياكل باستمرار في قيمه الفلوس
بالضبط زي اي فار بياكل في رزمه لقد ورقيه
طول ما هو بياكل فيها فهو بيتلف الفلوس دي
طالما انت سايبه براحته
والتضخم بيحصل في كل الدول باختلاف النسب
بتاعته طبعا من دوله للثانيه وظروف كل
دوله الداخليه والخارجيه لكن هو ظاهره
عالميه يعني لو انت عايش في امريكا وكان
معاك 1000 دولار في شهر يناير السنه اللي
فاتت 2022
فالالف دولار دول قيمتهم الحقيقيه دلوقتي
939$ تقريبا يعني قيمتهم قلت 61$ لان معدل
التضخم الثانوي الشهر اللي فات اللي هو
ديسمبر 2022 كان 6.5% هو بالمناسبه معدل
منخفض مقارنه مثلا ب
9.122 باختصار التضخم بيدمر قيمه الاموال
لو ثابت زي ما هي كده في شكلها النقطي
وعلشان كده ما ينفعش فلوسك تفضل مركونه
ولا هتخسر ايا كان البلد اللي انت عايش
فيه فلازم تحرك فلوسك من صورتها النقديه
الحاليه صوره ثانيه هنا بقى ركز معايا قوي
في اللي جاي علشان لو طبقت اللي هاقوله
وضعك المال غالبا هيتغير للاحسن باذن الله
في سؤالين هيجيئوا على بالك اولا ليه لازم
احرك فلوس يا اشرف ما هم مدفين في الشتاء
التضخم ده هاقول لك ليه علشان هدفيه الاول
نحفظ قيمتهم والثاني علشان ننميهم او
نزودهم والسؤال الثاني بقى يعني ايه احرك
فلوسي من صورتها النقديه الحاليه لصوره
ثانيه يعني ببساطه تبدل فلوسك باصول ثانيه
تقدر تحقق لك الهدفين اللي قلت لك عليهم
او على الاقل واحد منهم اللي هم حفظ قيمه
الفلوس وزياده ثاره الاصول الثانيه دي هي
الوحيده اللي تقدر تضخم وتتغلب عليه هل
معنى كده انك مش هتسيب معك كاش خالص لا
هتسيب كاش لكن بالقدر اللي يغطي مصاريفك
الشخصيه لمده ست شهور ومعهم مبلغ اضافي
مخصص لصندوق الطوارئ
الشخصيه انت لازم تكون عارفها اكلك
وايجارك فواتيركم مواصلاتك الى اخره فلو
مصاريفك الشخصيه مثلا 5000 جنيه في الشهر
اضرب في ست شهور ب 30,000 جنيه يتركنوا
على جنب ولو عرفت تشتري السلع اللي انت
محتاجها لصالحتها بتقعد فتره ست شهور دول
فاعمل كده واشتري من مكان بيبيع جمله
علشان توفر كمان مثلا اشتري استهلاكك من
المواد الغذائيه الاساسيه زي الرز والسكر
والشاي وغيرهم لمده ست شهور لو ده متاح طب
ايه صندوق الطوارئ ده ده مبلغ معين على
حسب تقديرك بيكون للمصاريف الطارئه غير
المتوقعه زي لا قدر الله بتكشف عندك طبيب
او عربيتك باظت او حاجه في البيت محتاجه
تصليح وغيره وهنبقى نعمل حلقه مفصله ان
شاء الله قريب جدا عن افضل وسيله لترتيب
واستغلال مصاريفك الشخصيه ومبلغ الطوارئ
بتاعك طيب خلاص جنبنا فلوس مصرفنا الشخصيه
والطوارئ المنتخب
الاساسي واجابته بمليون جنيه المبلغ اللي
باقي هنعمل به حاجه اسمها محافظه اول
الاسمنت بارتفوليو يعني ايه محفظه
استثماريه اوليه وبتتعمل ازاي وانواعها
وازاي تنوع الاستثمارات بتاعتك فيها ويعني
ايه اهدافك الاستثماريه ويعني ايه الافق
الزمني وازاي بتعرف تقيم مدى تحملك لمخاطر
الاستثمار من عدمه كل ده واكثر هنعرفه مع
بعض في حلقه النهارده باذن الله لكن قبل
كده عاوزكم تاخذوا بالكم من النسبه اللي
جنبي دي بشكل سريع جدا دي نسبه المشاهدين
من حضراتكم غير المشتركين في القناه لحد
اللحظه في ديسمبر اللي فات ده على طول
والناس دي اللي هي تقريبا نص مشاهدين
القناه شبه ثابته
لان اشتركم هو اهم حاجه بتساعدنا نكمل
ونطور من البرنامج وبالمناسبه الحلقات
مترجمه للغه الانجليزيه
[موسيقى]
الحلقه دي برعايه شركه عندها خبره طويله
في الاسواق الماليه بحجم تداولات شهريه
تجوزت مليون دولار هي شركه اكس مصر
العالميه ليه
علشان اربع مميزات الاولى انهم رخصه
ومراقبه من هيئه رقيه الثانيه ان بعرف
اسحب فلوسي بشكل فوري بدون تدخل بشري
الثالثه انه عملتهم منخفضه اما رابع حاجه
ان التداول بيتنفس بسرعه تقدر تفتح حساب
اسلامي لا محدود وتبدا تشتري وتبيع الاسهم
هتلاقوا لينك اليوم تحت الفيديو وفي
تعليقات فيسبوك نسبه كبيره من حضراتكم
عندهم محفظه استثماريه بالفعل ولكن مش
عارفين او مدركين ده لانه ببساطه حياتنا
معظمنا الماليه والاستثمارات بشكل ممكن
يكون عشوائي او غير مبني على نظام سليم
اهداف المحفظه الاستثماريه هي مجموعه من
الاصول والاستثمارات اللي بيحتفظ بها
وبيديرها الفرد او المؤسسه لتنميه فلوسهم
بمرور الوقت وبالتالي هي سي سلم من الاصول
والاستثمارات المختلفه بتسمح لنا بتوزيع
المخاطر وكسب عائد اعلى على بلاسنا وفي
السله دي هنلاقي جميع الاصول اللي
بنمتلكها صح كانت ذهب او عقارات الى اخره
وجميع الاستثمارات اللي بنمتلكها سواء
كانت اسهم او سندات او استثمارات خاصه زي
مشروع معين الى اخره هنا في نقطه مهمه
اللي مركز معي هياخذ باله منها ان انا
احيانا باقول اصول واحيانا باقول
استثمارات لان في اختلاف بين الاثنين
وركزوا معي في الجمله دي جميع الاستثمارات
هي اصول ولكن مش كل الاصول ينفع نقول
عليها استثمارات ببساطه شديده لو الاصل ده
احنا بنمتعه عشان يولد دخل او قيمته وتسيب
بمرور الوقت يبقى هو كده استثمار وبالتالي
دخل معنا في المحفظه على سبيل المثال
السياره هي اصلا لو الاستعمال الشخصي ما
ينفعش اقول عليها استثمار وبالتالي تطلع
عباره عن محفظه طب لو شغال عليها اوبر
مثلا كده بقت بتولد دخل وبالتالي بقى
تستثمار فتدخل معانا في المحفظه مثال ثاني
الشقه بتاعتي لو انا ساكن فيها فهي مش
هاستثمار طب لو شاريها وماجرها مثلا او
حتى اقفلها بس ومنتظر قيمتها تزيد فهي كده
بقت استثمار فتدخل معنا تحت بند اصلا
العقارات وبالتالي المحفظه الاستثماريه هي
جميع الاصول اللي بنمتلكها وبنحتفظ بها
بغرض توليب دخل او عائد او علشان قيمتها
بتزيد بمرور الوقت او الاثنين مع بعض زي
العقار اللي بنشتريه وبناجره وكده بيولد
دخل وفي نفس الوقت قيمته بتسيب بمرور
الزمن حلو قوي عايز اعمل محفظه استثماريه
اشرف ابدا منين هاقول لك لكن قبل ما ندخل
في التفاصيل والخطوات لازم تقرر الاول على
المحفظه دي انت هتعملها بنفسك ولا هتروح
لحد محترفه فاهم وخذ بالك احنا عندنا هنا
حاجتين اول حاجه ان شاء الله
مثلا معك 100,000 جنيه اتفقنا اننا مش
هنخلي الكاش معنا علشان الفار فاكره تضخم
يعني امال هنعمل ايه زي ما قلت لك قبل كده
هنشتروا اصول او استثمارات ب 100,000 جنيه
مثلا يعني هنشتري ب 50,000 جنيه ذهب
و30,000 جنيه اسهم في البورصه و20,000
جنيه هندخل بهم في استثمارات خاصه كده انت
عملت المحفظه خد بالك ده مجرد مثال
للتبسيط مش اكثر يعني مش باقول لك تعمل ده
بالحرف ان شاء الله المحفظه الحمد لله
الخطوه الثانيه بقى
هيبتها وادارتها والتعديل عليها وفقا
لاداء الاصول دي يعني ممكن ابيع جزء من
الاسهم او اكبر نسبه الذهب في المحفظه او
العكس او ممكن ابيع اسهم واشتري عقارات
وهكذا يعني انت او المستشارك المالي
بتراقبه وتعدله طول الوقت وفقا للاحداث
الماليه اللي انت محتاج توصل لها وطبعا
درجه المخاطره الادب تتحملها في ثلاث
خيارات لانشاء واداره المحفظه الاستثماريه
رقم واحد اداره المحفظه دي اي واي وهي
اختصار لي دويتيرس يعني يعملها بنفسك ودي
استراتيجيه بيختار فيها المستثمرين
الافراد انهم ينشئوا ويديروا محفظتهم او
استثماراتهم بنفسهم بشرط وجود خبره عندهم
عشان ما يخسروش فلوسهم رقم 2 استخدام ربع
فايزر او مستشار مالي قالت وطبعا مع ثوره
الذكاء الاصطناعي اتوقع مستقبلا انه هيكون
في انتشار لمستشارين ملايين محترفين
شغالين بالذكاء الاصطناعي ثلاثه انك تلجا
لحد محترف والحد ده هنا هو المستشار
المالي فايندشن »
وده بيكون شغلهم الاساسي وطبعا هنا بتدفع
رسوم انشائهم ودارتهم للمحفظه الاستثماريه
بتاعتك طيب ايا كان مين هيعمل القصه دي
السؤال هنا بقى هتعمل المحفظه الاستثماريه
زي برده اول حاجه هتعملها بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم كده هتعمل تقييم لوضعك يعني ايه
يعني ترم كل ورقك على الترابيزه علشان
نفهم مكانك وعايز تروح فين لو انت رايح
لمستشار مالي علشان تعمل محافظه هي لك
اول حاجه هيكون محتاج يعرفها هو وضع كمال
الحالي هيعمل تقييم شامل لكل الاصول اللي
عندك ولازم يعرف التدفقات النقديه عندك او
بمعنى ابسط مصادر داخلك ولو عندك
استثمارات وحجم ديونك ومدخراتك النقديه
ومصاريفك الشهريه الى اخره باختصار بيرسم
خريطه كامله لوضعك المال الحالي ده وبيعرف
كل حاجه بالتفصيل قبل ما ياخذ اي اجراء
بيساعده في تحديد مسار تطوير استراتيجيه
الاستثمار اللي هتمشي عليها في المحفظه
طيب عملنا كده يا اشرف ايه اللي بعد كده
في خطوه رئيسيه في بناء محفظتك
الاستثماريه وهي تحديد هدفك الاستثمار
يعني ليه انت عاوز تستثمر او اسبابك
للاستثمار ده جثه اساسي من خطتك لو وقفت
تاكس في الشارع وركبت معه مش هيتحرك غير
لما يعرف انت عايز تروح فين هتقول له
هيبدا يتحرك وانت راكب معه احتمال تقول له
معلش ممكن تمشي بسرعه شويه علشان عندي
ميعاد مهم فهيمشي بسرعه وممكن يدخل من
طريق مختصر او ممكن يكون هو ماشي بسرعه
اصلا فتقول له يبطئ سرعته لانك مش مستعجل
ده بالضبط سبب تحديد هدفك من الاستثمار
لان ده بيساعدنا في تحديد انواع
الاستثمارات او الاصول المناسبه اللي
هتضيفها لمحفظتك هتشتري دهب ولا على قرار
ولا اسهم ولا هتمول شركه ناشئه ولا هتعمل
ايه كل ده هيتوقف على تحديد هدفك
الاستثماري الدراسات نفسها بتظهر اهميه
تحديد الاهداف للوصول للنجاح المالي في
دراسه شهيره اتعملت سنه 1979 على خريج
برنامج ماجستير اداره الاعمال في جامعه
هارفار 3% من الخريجين كانوا عارفين
اهدافهم الماليه ومحددانها والباقي كانوا
سايبينها على الظروف بعد 10 سنين من
التخرج وتحديدا سنه 1989 راحوا لهم ثاني
ولا لقوهم بيكسبوا 10 اضعاف اللي بيحصل
عليه 97% الباقيين مج وبالتالي ما ينفعش
نكون ماشيين بالبركه كده ما ينفعش نعمل
محفظه استثماريه واحنا مش عارفين عاوزين
منها ايه بالظبط فلازم نحدد هدفنا وطبعا
ممكن يكون في اكثر من هدف استثماري مش هدف
واحد بس نحدد الاهداف دي بدقه علشان نعرف
نوجه المركب او نعمل المحفظه بطريقه
تخليها تحقق الاهداف دي وهضرب لكم بعض
الامثله دلوقتي علشان الفكره توضح اكثر بس
قبلها في حاجه مهمه جدا لازم نحددها مع
الهدف الاستثماري ده هو الافق الزمني او
تايم يعني ايه اشرف الافق الزمن ده كمان
هو ببساطه شديده مقدار الوقت اللي انت
هتحتاج الفلوس اللي بتستمرها بعده يعني
هتحتاج الفلوس بعد وقت قد ايه بالضبط قبل
ما اضرب لك امثله بتوضح الفكره سريع بس
خلينا نوضح لك حاجه مهمه مرتبطه في تقسيم
الاهداف وفقا للقفق الزمن كثير بنسمع عن
استثمار قصير الاجل او متوسط الاجل او
طويله الاجل بس مش عارفين ايه المقصود
بيهم يعني يعني ايه واحد استثمر فلوسه
واستثمار قصير الاجل مثلا كم سنه يعني
قصير ولا متوسط ولا طويل الاجل ده هقول لك
لاستثمار قصير الاجل ده بيكون اقل من ثلاث
سنين لاستثمار متوسط الاجل بيكون بين ثلاث
سنين وعشر سنين لاستثمار طويل الاجل بقى
بيكون اكبر من 10 سنين تمام كده سهله اهي
تعالوا بقى نضرب شويه امثله بسيطه ووضح
اللي فات ده مثلا هتيجي تقول انا معي
200,000 جنيه وعاوز اعمل محفظه استثماريه
بهم بس هاحتاجهم بعد سنتين علشان عايز
اتجوز كده حددت الهدف من الاستثمار وهو
الزواج مع الافق الزمن بتاعك اللي هو هنا
سنتين فالمستشار المالي هيضبط المحفظه
باستثمارات تكون قصيره الاجل بحيث تحقق
هدفك هو الزواج بعد سنتين بالضبط مثال
ثاني انت معك 500,000 جنيه وعاوز تشتري
شقه بعد اربع سنين من دلوقت مثلا في منطقه
ما علشان تتجوز فيها فانت كده محتاج تظبط
المحفظه باست متوسطه الاجل علشان تحقق
الهدف بتاعك بعد اربع سنين وهكذا حاجه
اخيره عايز اقولها فيما يتعلق بالهدف من
الاستثمار وهي انه لازم يكون قابل للتحقيق
ما يكونش هدف صعب جدا يتحقق او شبه مستحيل
يعني ما تجيش مثلا تقول انا معي 50,000
جنيه وعاوزه اشتري شقه بعد سنه مش منطقي
فلازم يكون الهدف قابل للتحقيق في بقى
الشريحه كبيره من الناس هتقول انا عايز
احفظ قيمه فلوسي بس هو ده هدف الوحيد
دلوقتي فلو انت بتتفرج عليا وهدفك هو انك
تحفظ قيمه فلوسك من التضخم فانا جاي لك
دلوقت اهو ممكن نعتبر ده هدف ولكن الدقه
هو مكانه مش هنا مكانه مش ضمن اهداف
الاستثمار وده ياخذنا للضلع الثالث اللي
لازم تحدده علشان نعمل المحفظه لاستثماريه
بتاعتنا احنا عندنا ضلعين اساسيين لازم
نحددهم زي ما قلنا الاول هو الهدف من
الاستثمار والثاني الافق الزمني الضلع
الثالث بقى والمهم جدا جدا هو درجه
المخاطره
قادر تتحملها معنى ايه الكلام ده هاقول لك
وركز معي الله يخليك علشان ده مهم جدا انا
وانت واحمد وعلي ومايكل وزينب وحنان
ونورهان وكل الناس مختلفين عن بعض في تحمل
درجه المخاطره كل شخص شهيته للمخاطره
مختلفه عن الثاني يعني لو انا معي مثلا
100,000 جنيه هو كل الفلوس اللي انا
بامتلكها انا كاشرف مستعده جازف بهم كلهم
بس حقق اعلى عائد منهم اعرف صديقه ثاني
بقى له ثمان سنين كل ما يشوف وشي يقول لي
عايز اعمل مشروع ب 20,000 جنيه عايز بس
خائف لا خساره المخاطره بتاعته قليله جدا
ما عندوش استعداد يخسر ولا جزء بسيط من
الفلوس
ده لان المخاطره في درجات في النصف فلازم
تعرف انت واقف في انهي منطقه بالضبط طيب
ايه اهميه ان اعرف درجه المخاطره اللي انا
مستعد اتحملها ببساطه لان درجه تحملك
للمخاطر هيخليك الاستثمارات والاصول اللي
هتبني المحفظه بهم في ارتباط كبير بين
المخاطر والعوائد يا اخواننا الاثنين
ماشيين مع بعض كده لو انت عاوز عوائد
كبيره على استثماراتك فده معنان لدرجه
تحملك للمخاطره لازم تكون كبيره مخاطر
كبيره بتساوي عوائد كبيره والعكس صحيح لو
انت خايف على خساره راس مالك او جزء منه
فانت كده مستوى تحمله لك للمخاطر قليل
وبالتالي فلازم تعرف ان العائد على
استثماراتك واصولك هيكون قليل تحمل
المخاطر بيعتمد على العوامل الشخصيه ما
فيهوش صح وغلط بالمناسبه كل واحد ادرى
بظروفه الشخصيه والماليه في ناس بتتعرض
لضغوط نفسيه لو خست جزء من فلوسها وفي ناس
ما عندهاش فرصه لتكوين راس المال بتاعها
ده ثاني وبالتالي فخايفه تخسره وفي ناس
مسؤولين عن ناس ثانيين وبالتالي ما عندهمش
رفاهيه خساره ولا جزء صغير من مدخراتهم كل
الانواع دي درجه تحملهم لان المخاطره
قليله وده مش غلط
الناحيه الثانيه في مثلا ناس بيمتلكوا
رؤوس اموال ضخمه حد مثلا ربنا يوسع علينا
وعليكم ثروته 10 مليون جنيه يجيء مثلا
يقول عاوز اعمل محفظه استثماريه باثنين
مليون جنيه وبالتالي فعند القدره على تحمل
الخساره ودرجه محاضرته عاليه او كبيره وده
بيخلق فرص لمكاسب اكبر طيب كثير مننا
غالبا ما يعرفش درجه المخاطره بتاعته
متلخبط او محتار مثلا او مش قادر يحدد فهي
العمل في الحاله دي لو في مستشار مالي او
مخطط مالي هتستعين به علشان يبني محفظتك
الاستثماريه فهو بيكون عنده ادوات معينه
زي اختبارات تحمل المخاطر بتكون مجموعه
كبيره من الاسئله جزء منها بيتجاوب عليه
بنعم او لا والجزء الثاني بتكون اسئله
محتاجه اجابات اكثر تفصيل علشان يعرف من
خلالها رد فعلك لو انت بتستثمر فلوسك في
السوق بالفعل يعني يقول لك مثلا لو عندك
ذهب وفجاه بدات اسعار الذهب بتنزل علشان
البنك المركزي رفع اسعار الفائده مثلا
فانت فتحه هيكون ايه هتجري تبيع ولا
هتنتظر ولا هتروح تشتري ذهب ثاني والاسعار
منخفضه كده فهو بيعرف من اجابات الاسئله
دي بشكل عام نقدر نقسم تحمل المخاطر
لثلاث مستويات من الاقل للاكثر خطوره
مستوى الاول متحفظ او كونسيالفاتيف وده في
الاشخاص اللي بيفضلوا الامان وبيحبه
يتجنبوا الخساره بدل من المحاضره نظير
المكاسب كبيره ودول غالبا بيكونوا الكبار
في السن او مستواهم المادي قليل المستوى
الثاني معتدل او المدد ودول الاشخاص اللي
بيقدروا يتحملوا بعض المخاطر ولكن لحد
معين يعني بيكون عندهم استعداد لخساره جزء
من فلوسهم مقابل حصولهم على فرصه لتحقيق
مكاسب كبيره ولكن من خطرش بكل راس المال
المستوى الثالث جريء او هجومي
ودول الاشخاص اللي عندهم استعداد لتحمل
مخاطر كبيره عادي يعني يخسروا كل فلوسهم
مقابل فرصه تحقيق مكاسب ما هو دول غالبا
بيكونوا صنعهم صغير لان بي عندهم وقت
يعوضوا خسارهم او اشخاص اثرياء بالفعل
وعندهم فوائد ماليه ثانيه بتعوض الخسايه
اجمالا الاشخاص المحافظين اللي ما عندهمش
استعداد للمخاطره محافظهم لاستثماريه
هتركز على الاصول الاكثر استقرار الاشخاص
الجارين اللي عندهم تحمل شديد للمخاطر
محافظهم هتركز على الاصول المتقلبه
للاشخاص المعتدلين بقى محافظهم هيكون فيها
اصول متنوعه وبالمناسبه مش لازم تصنف نفسك
في مستوى واحد من مستويات الثلاثه ممكن
تعمل اكثر من محفظه كل محفظه تكون بمستوى
مخاطره مختلفه عن الثاني طيب كده حددنا او
عرفنا اربع حاجات مهمه جدا حجم المحفظه
الهدف من الاستثمار والاوفق الزمني وتعرج
التحمل المخاطر بعد كده بقى تيجي لمرحله
الاخطر والاهم عباره عن ايه المرحله دي يا
اشرف بناء المحفظه الاستثماريه نفسها وده
اللي بنسميه تخصيص الاصول او اثاوكاشه
يعني ايه الاصول دي يعني توزيع فلوسك على
الاصول المختلفه اتفقنا ان فلوسنا دي
هنشتري بقى استثمارات واصول ونبني المحفظه
هنشتري ايه بقى هنوزع الفلوس على انواع
مختلفه من الاصول على حسب هدفك من
الاستثمار وعلى حسب الافق الزمني وعلى حسب
درجه تحملك للمخاطر المشكله بس ده احنا
هنحدد انهي فئه اصول بالضبط يعني مثلا
هنشتري معادن ب 30% من حجم المحفظه طيب
معادن ايه ذهب ولا فضه مثلا طب لو هنشتري
ذهب هنشتري سبائك ولا ذهب مستعمل ولا ايه
هنخصص اسهم في المحفظه طب الاسهم دي هتكون
اسهم محليه يعني لو انت في مصر هتكون اسكن
في البورصه المصريه ولا بورصه تانيه في
احدى الاسواق الناشئه ولا بورصه من
البورصه الامريكيه مثلا
بالضبط اسهم شركات صغيره ولا متوسطه ولا
كبيره هنخصص استثمار عقاري في المحفظه في
حيكون عباره عن ايه بالضبط وهكذا في
النهايه عمليه بناء المحفظه هي عمليه
كبيره وفيها تفاصيل كتير وبناء المحفظه او
تخصيصول من اهم الحاجات واخطارها في
المحافظ الاستعماريه وطبعا بعد كده
محتاجين نتكلم عن انواع المحافظ ومراقبه
المحفظه وقعدت التوازن بتاعها الى اخره
لكن علشان ما اطولش على حضراتكم هاكتفي
بالقدر ده في الحلقه دي وان شاء الله نعمل
حلقه ثانيه نكمل فيها كلامنا عن المحافظ
الاستثماريه ويا ريت تعرفوني في التعليقات
لو حابين اننا نكمل عموما في مسار اداره
الاموال الشخصيه والمنتخب ده وفي النهايه
عندي لكم سؤال يا ريت اشوفكم بتجاوبوه في
التعليقات يا ترى درجه تحملك للمخاطر قد
ايه ولا ايه هتابع اجابتكم كلها في
التعليقات اللي عايز يشتري اسهم او دهب ما
تنسوش تشوفوا شركه اكسنس هتلاقوا رابط تحت
الفيديو وما تنسوش لو ما تنسوش مشتركين في
القناه وتفعلوا شر الجرس علشان توصل لكم
الحلقه الثانيه لما تتعرض ولو كنت مشتركين
بس مش مفعلين زر الجرس ففعلوه علشان يجيء
لكم اشعار بالحلقه اول ما تنزل ان شاء
الله
سلام
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]